كريس في بعض الأحيان
المقابلات التليفزيونية
وقد مرت بها كل شبكة تقريبًا
[موسيقى]
من المواجهات التي تتخطى
فيها ما نفعله للتغلب على المشكلة ، لا ،
لا نظرة ، لا أريد القيام بذلك
والانهيارات
العرضية للكثيرين  إن إجراء هذه المقابلات
يبدو بسيطًا ،
فقط شخصان يجريان محادثة
ولكن
بالنسبة لأولئك الذين يفعلون ذلك من أجل لقمة العيش ، فهذا
شكل من أشكال الفن ،
خذ كبير المذيعين الدوليين في
CNN كريستيان أمانبور ،
فأنا لست قاسيًا دائمًا ولكن يمكنني أن أكون قاسيًا ،
لكني أنا عادلة سيدتي الرئيسة
لديك  تم تصنيفك كواحد من أسوأ
القادة في العالم
سواء كان الأمر يتعلق بالتحدي لقادة العالم إلى
أين يأخذ الأمر ، لا يهمني أن
يكون هناك شخص ما يحاسب أولئك الذين في السلطة
يكون قرارًا للبرلمان ،
هذا هو كيف يمكنك شخصيا
أن تمزح معي.
البرنامج أو الخوض في حياة
الملوك في ثقافة البوب
ستيان كانت على رأس بع
المقابلات الأكثر شهرة في CNN وا
متحمسة حول البيئة هي
من إنكلترا
هي من إيران. ما هي صفقتها التي
ولدت في لندن ونشأت في طهران
أمانبور بدأت في مكتب الخارجية في
CNN في عام 1983
مع مهنة صحفية امتدت لما يقرب من
أربعة عقود
وكل جائزة تلفزيونية كبرى تحت
حزامها هناك عدد قليل من الأشخاص
الذين لديهم  سمّرت فن المقابلة
بشكل أفضل من كريستيان ،
لذلك طلبنا منها بعض النصائح
[موسيقى] ،
عليك حقًا معرفة الحقائق التي نولي
اهتمامًا كبيرًا لإخراج جميع أسلحة الدمار الشامل
من منطقة الشرق الأوسط.
إذا قمت ببحث جيد فعليك أن تكون مستعدًا جيدًا حقًا ، فلا
أحد يصدقك
بشكل أساسي لأن
كل ما قلته على مدار العامين
ونصف العام الماضيين قد تم
التخلص منه ببساطة بسبب الحقائق
التي يجب عليك الاستماع إلى ما
يقوله لك الشخص وتعرفه
متى تلتقط التحدي ومتابعته
أو تحاول توسيع نطاق ما يقولون
إنك ستوقع نفسك في
المشاكل لأن ما قلته بشكل
قاطع للتو هو أن
هذا  لا يمثل مشكلة بالنسبة لنا بالنسبة
للشعب الكيني ،
فأنا أريد أن أصبح رئيسًا لوزراء
باكستان ، أفضل
سؤال يثير
إجابة حقيقية أو يثير مفاجأة أو
يثير دفاعًا أو يثير شيئًا
لم يتوقعوه أنه لا يزال لديك
أحلام كبيرة لم يأخذوها
بعيدًا عنك ،
يمكنهم فقط إطلاق النار على جسد ،
لكنهم لا يستطيعون إطلاق النار على أحلامي ،
فالطبيعة تمقت الفراغ ، لا
يحب الناس الصمت ،
إنهم جيدون ، أعتقد أنها
رسالة جيدة
أعتقد أنها رسالة جيدة يشعرون غالبًا
بالحرج  أو محرجًا أو أيًا
كان الأمر ويريدون ملؤه
، وأحيانًا يمنحك ذلك أفضل
الحكايات من المعلومات
[موسيقى]
مع إخبارك أنك حاولت
وضع ذلك أعتقد أنه تم
العثور عليه
مسؤولاً ،
فهذا لا يتعلق بنوع من اللحظات المسدودة ،
حسنًا ، إنه ليس كذلك  قائمة مسكتك ،
إنها ما يسمى بلحظات مسكتك ،
يمكنك تجربة بعض الأسئلة
الضرورية وبعضها يعمل ولكن
إذا كان كل ما تفعله هو
مسكك وساخر ، فلن تصل إلى
أي مكان وستجد  الجمهور لا
يحب ذلك أيضًا
[الموسيقى] ،
هل يمكنني فقط مخاطبة الفيل في
الغرفة التي ترتدي فيها نظاراتك الداكنة ،
الأشخاص الذين يشاهدونهم
يريدونني أن أصل إلى حقيقة ما
يجعل الإنسان على ما هو عليه شخصيًا
ومهنيًا  لا أعرف ربما
أصبحوا مجرد عكاز وجزء
من أنا
سأكون صادقًا وصادقًا
وجيدًا ، لن أذهب أبدًا
إلى نهاية التحقيق
لأنني سأفكر يا
إلهي إذا سألت هذا السؤال الصعب ،
هل سأعيد
هذا الشخص مرة أخرى مسيحي نعم أم
لا
عهد بسيط بالطبع حتى أفضل
المحاورين يجدون شيئًا
كهذا ،
يجب أن تكون دقيقًا عندما تتحدث
مع الأجيال ، شكرًا وداعًا
ولكن بالنسبة لكريستيان ، إنها مناسبة نادرة
لم أحصل على الكثير من الإضرابات لأكون
صادقين لا يميلون  لفعل ذلك بي
أنا فقط لا أعتقد أنهم  يريدون الخروج ،
أعتقد أنهم يريدون الجلوس هناك
وإثبات أنهم يعرفون أنهم أجابوا
على الأسئلة
أو لم يفعلوا